bacon thank you
hi guys my name's Steve Anthony Lawrence
I was beans uneven Stevens
everybody has it beans in their life or
they are the beans if you can't think of
one you are the top pretty fake cries
I've ever heard two of them belong to me
thanks I've got skills you know you work
five days a week with people for four
years and it's a set like that you
become very very very very close to
people you know it was like a family
there was not a dry eye in the studio on
the last finale
John has his wacky side maybe I like me
because I kind of have a wacky side to I
guess but you know he has a huge heart
he'd literally give you the shirt off of
his back I mean I still lived in Fresno
actually when I was shooting the show
like my god was driving me back and
forth you know put a lot of miles on
cars and Shia one day just kind of
surprised me with an Xbox on my on
Christmas well from now on your name is
beans my bean
kid a nickname is not supposed to be
logical tea it's supposed to be fun
audition process was pretty cool
actually um you know he had free reeds
you know then you have your callbacks my
thing my personal thing that I always
did as an actor as a kid at least was I
kind of feel out the room see if they
were kinda in a rush or not if they were
kind of connecting good as they want to
hear a joke so I told this pirate joke
there was a pirate on a ship
get off me
[Music]
it was like kind of the first kind of
stuff thing I had to do they lowered me
down like mission impossible while the
girls were sleeping
it was the most jerry-rigged stunt ever
it was like one of those pulley systems
all this grip needed to do but for me to
just piss him off once eight or
something go I am still doing classes I
do only charge 40 bucks a week
I teach kids I think all ages anybody
that's hungry I think it's a big big big
blessing to get kids to cert learn
technique at an early age instead of
just making faces in front of the camera
winner ask me kids these can be pretty
darn smart attire and
maybe maybe I can't again I'm again
actually say anything right now about
that so